[Music]
another day another Megan Markel
sighting this time with the sweetest
surprise the Dutchess of Sussex looked
flawless while watching Harry and
William go head-to-head at the king
power royal charity polo day on
Wednesday
her long beachy waves perfect Sunny's
and flowy olive green midi just scream
effortless chic I never thought my life
would be that awesome but the best part
of Megan's look was the adorable little
bundle in her arms yes the 37 year old
mama brought baby
Archie along to cheer on his
polo-playing Poppa at the event
it's pretty amazing photographer is
caught making kissing cradling and
smiling at her two-month-old son making
us so completely gaga but Archie wasn't
the only royal kiddo at the charity
match which according to a Kensington
Palace press release will help raise
funds and awareness for the charities
supported by their Royal Highnesses Kate
Middleton also showed up looking
gorgeous
in a simple pink dress with George
Charlotte and Louie in tow and were
still laughing about this moment when
Louie went rogue kids will be kids even
when their royal the family outing comes
just days after both the Cambridge's and
the Sussex a--'s joined forces to
celebrate Archie's christening which was
held at the private chapel at Windsor
Castle of course Harry Megan and Archie
reside at the nearby Frogmore cottage
where royal expert Katie Nichol told us
that they have essentially built a
fortress one of their closest friends
told me it was their oasis their
sanctuary where they're going to raise
their child away from the spotlight I
think the couple are determined for
Archie to have as normal a life as
possible meanwhile mama megan seems to
be ramping up her public appearances
despite reportedly being unlit Erna t
leave until fall I was brought up in the
entertainment industry it was a very
comfortable environment for me
et has learned that the Duchess is
expected to attend the UK premiere of
Disney's live-action remake of The Lion
King on Sunday marking her first red
carpet since giving birth to Archie the
dream also on Megan's summer agenda a
guest editing gig with British Vogue a
source tells et that she'll be
reflecting on causes near and dear to
her heart including women's empowerment
and education which form the basis of
her charity work my biggest focus has
been gender equality and women's rights
all starting from something that
happened when I was really young and
she's expected to participate in some
photos at Frogmore to supplement the
issue but before you go getting too
excited the source adds that there's no
agreement in place at this point for the
Duchess to participate in a regular
column for us booked with Anna Wintour
one can only hope I don't know anyone
who just does one thing anymore and as
women I don't think we've ever just done
one thing we do it all
[Music]
[Applause]